this week conflict zone is in Hornady
near Munich to talk to Angelika Niebla
she is a member of the European
Parliament for Bavaria's conservative
Christian social Union at a time of
growing divisions in Europe over
religion and migration we ask her should
politicians not be avoiding religious
issues
[Music]
argh you can even welcome to conflict
zone hello mr. Feeny it appears that the
European Union is massively struggling
with religion at the moment particularly
with Islam isn't it well actually in the
member states we have a lot of debates
on the question of Islam and and and
Muslim refugees and and issues like that
on the European Union level we
concentrate you know and on on on on
asylum policy introducing their debates
into the European Union these are not
too differentiated levels I'm very sorry
they are not differentiated and of
course on the European level we take
note of what's happening in the Member
States in all of the Member States but
if you ask me as a politician I'm a
member of the European Parliament and I
have to concentrate on my work I'm doing
over there and what we are doing right
now is trying you know to sort out the
troubles and find a common approach on
the asylum and at the same time you are
a time you're a conservative that means
you are in the same group like your
party friend Viktor Orban so let's speak
a little bit about the reality of Europe
also of the European Union and the
influence of all these debates Hungarian
Prime Minister Viktor Orban is leading
the chorus of warnings about Islam quote
we don't consider these people as Muslim
refugees we consider them as Muslim
invaders unquote do you agree I would
not use the words he used and I do not
agree on that term but well this is this
is politics in in Hungary in terms of
politics in hang in Europe it's also
politics about Germany Germany is
crawling with Hungary about these point
of views don't try to isolate all that
no I'm not isolating you know I mean in
Europe and the European Parliament and
I'm carefully you know intervene
debating and discussing with people and
with my colleagues in the political
party on our chairman approach on asylum
policy on migration will connect to this
another quote nations will cease to
exist the West will fall while Europe
won't even realize it has been invaded
that's quite dressed a drastic talk mr.
Obon your friend also in the EPP well
this well the feeders is a within the
EPP group that is correct so you know
I'm not as stressed you know this is
never something I would say like that
and I do not agree on the on the on the
it's well above whenever you use a an
expression like invasion I think you
have to find out what do you mean by
that yeah if he Obon wanted to express
you know that a lot of people came to
too hungry at a certain time this is if
if that is going to be considered know
he's speaking about that 27:18 let me
finish you know I think then then he
Hitler he would like he would describe a
situation there but if if you interpret
it in a different way and then then I
think I would not agree on that and and
again you know if if you want to find
out was what mr. Orban says I would know
I know that's too easy I mean this way
of arguing is too easy
firstly he is a part in the UPPP that
means you are in one family so the
question is what is about this member of
your family do you agree or not
secondly mr. Obon is one of the states
in Europe and that means Hungarian
parliamentarians Hungarian people are
influencing or so polish ones politics
in Europe and that's why we I think we
have to continue to talk a little bit
because I would like to understand your
position Albin said about Muslims every
single migrant poses a public security
and terrorist
this is hate speech
every every single migrant poses a
public security and terrorists every
Muslim is not a terrorist
again mr. Friedman this is not what I
support this is not my opinion this is
not my party's opinion you mentioned
that feeders and mr. ovens party is
member of our EPP Curtis that is correct
and I think there is a big chance for us
also to debate on on issues like that to
criticize and to try to convince him
also to to slightly it doesn't listen it
doesn't listen to you well it doesn't
seem maybe may change opinion you maybe
not now you know it's always a process
and I think we have to understand what
both bodies arguments are for for for
expressions like damn simply condemn
that and and say very well what do you
mean am i I clearly stated again I
clearly stated it's not my wording I
don't this is the condemnation this is
that you are not not my wording it's not
my wording I don't agree on what he has
said but and and we have to talk about
what he meant by that and if I do not
agree to him then I will let him know
when I have a chance to do that we have
all our party meetings so we will meet
in I think in tune we will have a
meeting here Munich will have a big
meeting at the end of the year so there
is an ongoing process and ongoing
discussion and debate on issues like
that but you know condemnation is a very
hard word yeah and again I am saying are
not yet words he's a European he's a
member in the European Union so mr.
Friedman is also a politician you know
and he was completely fallacious no it's
not an art of course it's not an excuse
of racism but well I try to understand
and I try to find out the reasoning
behind don't know the reason behind why
a man like Albin is saying all these
things well it's it's not it's perhaps
election campaigns its power play well
it's populist course when you under you
know it perfectly well when you're in
the political debate and discussions you
are some sometimes exaggerating but I
agree with you in the sense that you
know you have to be careful if you talk
about innovation you have to this is a
tough word again which I would never use
and which I would never exist what you
wish to speak and to talk about European
level so let's talk about article 21 of
the European Charter saying quote any
discrimination based on any ground such
as religion shall be prohibited the
foreign minister of Luxembourg hustla
bond accused Viktor Orban he found words
of violation the EU Charter and demanded
strong sanctions again Hungary
can you understand Mr Bond well again I
can understand that according to his
interpretation this is absolutely not
acceptable do you mind looking at the
European Union I think what is what is
what do we have as a task what do we
have to do and what we have to do is
just to show that it's not okay you know
using wordings and using expressions
like that sanctions and and and say well
the sanctions I start with trying to
understand what's what's the reasoning
behind I learned that the found demand
of the European Union in the ground
human rights are certain if a member
state represented by a prime minister or
two even three don't respect human
rights for example discrimination and
the word is not seeing any reaction how
do you want that you are respected when
you are telling others the foundation
our human rights
if you and your own family and are doing
as much as possible that this is
happening again what we are doing in our
EPP family is to controversially discuss
issues like that
they know when this
this had been done and we and we will
continue today red lines
well again yes would you introduce the
pens party no we wouldn't introduce in
the rhetoric about Islam between the
right-wing parties and all bands
expressions yeah well I think there is a
difference again I'm not I'm not taking
up his wording and his expressions yeah
and let us talk in our EPP group about
about about the campaigning and
everything we have to do that by the way
because the next election for the
European Parliament will take place next
year in May so will if he's and he is in
the family and we think he should stay
in the family huh then we have to we
have little messages are going to you
that's what I want you say woodley leave
your lose your majority that's one of
the points why you say we need them mr.
Friedman listen you know a politician
isn't a politician who does not want to
get a good vote in the elections who
does not go for maturity I think he's
not a good politician either but that's
not the only that's really not the only
reason we have our values and we we have
a common ground in the EPP group and and
I learned that not only mr. Assad born
which who does not belong to our
political group but colleagues from our
political group also have some
reservations on on on on on things said
during the election okay so to talk
about that we have and to see how we are
going on but let me finish you know I
ask you the question how do you
influence how do you try to change to
change things to to to move things
forward in in a direction which you
think is the right way yeah my feeling
is if you come with sanctions if you are
coming with punishment if you are this
is not the right word I think blaming
and shaming is good I think you know
having an open and frank and
controversial debate
Scot and of course if all that is not
bringing the positive results then you
have to think about other I understand
things but the point I understand your
point fair enough
but if other things like the state of
law and other problems are changing then
the question is if this dialogue idea
that you are presenting is not at the
end appeasement in his country in
Hungary or in Poland a lot of civil
rights are not anymore existing as they
have to be after our principles the
population is paying a certain price so
look this is only the other side of your
argument your court referred to what had
been said during the election campaign
so this is quite new and and again you
know we we have the discussion we have
the debate we had a long debate in the
European Parliament in our plenary the
discussions are ongoing and we have
instruments let me just finish please
and we have instruments you know if
someone is not sticking to the rules
then we have a mechanism we have a
mechanism which is going to be
introduced and right now we are watching
the observing and if it's changing then
the other instruments of the Executive
Board of the CSU which far from
distancing itself from Albin keeps
inviting him as a guest of honor to
party retreats isn't that isn't this a
fatal signal again if you don't
criticize it we are not related we have
a we have a long history with Hungary
we as per variants we speak about this
and we have we have close cooperation
also on the economic field on
educational field on you know arranging
for exchanges in everything between
Bavaria and between Hungary Viktor
Viktor Orban we know for 20 yes 30 years
so what yes sir what is that an argument
no it's not it's an argument for talking
it's an argument for exchanging but
it is so nice in local time co-leader
Jose over let's speak really to the
point now federal interior minister has
said we this is you
we should not demonize demonize urban is
it not mr. Orban doing the demonizing by
calling refugees Muslim invaders
why is he protecting mr. Albin he is
protecting know he's against criticism
he is in dialogue with mr. urban my
party leader is also in dialogue with
mr. Putin it's not on my part in
dialogue with quite a lot of difference
with quite a lot of state representative
he's judging don't demonize him and he's
embracing him and the word can watch out
that well again we'll try to understand
what's going on in in Hungary yeah and
mr. Freidman I think we have to realize
that we had a an election in Hungary
yeah
with a huge participation in in the
polls people wanted to pull people
waited in front you know of the polls to
to vote and and you know that it was a
huge majority which supported mr.
orbán's line politically lined so this
is not an justification but I think this
is also part of of accepting the reality
as it is our elections also reasoning
Bavaria we will have in a few months
election that your party leader or say
over not only embrace mr. Albin but it's
very near to him political ideas has
ever said Islam does not belong to
Germany mr. Albin is to say saying the
same German is characterized by
Christianity and it depends on what do
you mean by Islam is belonging to
Germany it's not belonging to Germany
what do you want to express and the
second sentence mr. my party leader also
stressed was of course Muslims
living in Germany they are part of
channel thank you so much they're
Germans won't any politician but we want
you to express that is you know that the
religion know that the religion is not
what is what had been our identity our
cultural roots which we followed that is
very seriously that is not very long to
Germany he was not saying Islam didn't
belong he is in the present time in the
present time the Chancellor answered to
this rhetoric great tricks and and she
answered very quickly she said quote
Moslems belong to Germany that is also
what mister zero and their religion
Islam belongs here just as much unfold
who is right Matt was a gopher I ask you
another question what is our cultural
identity yeah you know you were
traveling to Bavaria coming over you I
appreciate that concrete yeah but but
not again you know what is our cultural
identity and I again it's our Christian
Jewish roots please okay take it away
not the Jewish one let's concentrate on
the Christian well yes which which are
here or November area in every village
you're traveling around you will see the
churches being PP being here so this is
what what what what had been our
tradition our culture this these are the
wellness upon which you know our common
come in our society is built upon her
and and the same the same is not true
for Islam yeah
the same is not true for Islam that's
the only thing we want to express in
your area what are our cultures Islam
belongs here just as much is not saying
a left politician it's mrs. Merkel who
said this
with all your explanation thank you very
much for these historical explanation
about Christianity we are 2018 she said
their religion are part of Germany not
only these ones who are here who is
right Merkel or zero I do not see a big
difference between Angela Merkel and
between horsey over what two years about
that no no no I think it's well if you
if you interpret this sentence in the
sense that part of our cultural identity
is the Christianity which you will find
all of the point I'm very sorry no
that's the point
today 2018 again we are here in a
liberal free state is the Islam a part
of Germany yes or no Islam is a religion
which really Islam is a religion and we
we do only want the freedom of religion
yes like this is according to how I how
I used this sentence how I interpret
this sentence Islam is not a part of
Germany okay I agree I agree I fully
agree with that sentence
I'm formulated by mr. C Hofer yeah but
let me stress you know you have to to
have you have you have to give me the
chance to interpret you know what is
meant by that sentence yeah you did it
okay let's go to Christianity yes sir de
the prime the state premier of Bavaria
has implemented a policy now a few
months before the elections in Bavaria
of hanging the Christian cross in all of
Bavaria state-run offices the german
constitution however guarantees the
neutrality of the state to its religion
he's breaking their constitution isn't
he he's not breaking the institution
come on and by the way it's not you know
the debate on the cross we had for ages
yeah we also had but there was a time
they don't
whether it's allowed to have a cross in
the class in school this for years if
not mr. tsuda wouldn't have obliged to
mr. pavement we have a debate on what
what what what are our cultures what are
our values I'm sorry that I have that
I'm repeating myself but I think it's
important to stress it and and the the
cross it's not only a religious symbol
but it's also you know symbolizing you
know what our culture's bishops told you
how are you like that the cross symbol
of the Christian religion nothing else
don't start with cultures it's not me it
was Cardinal Marx who mentioned you want
to you want to misinterpret me so again
when I'm I'm also using a cross I'm a
Christian here but for me it's also an
expression you know of both what what we
what we are standing for what are our
common values what is our cultural
identity here and this is not this is
not jeopardizing that for a Christian
you know the cross has a why not another
symbol in other meanings you know that
the situation is very emotional eyes you
know that there is a debate between
these religion issues why now now I want
to accept what you just mentioned had a
Jewish Christian time so if this is the
case and the cross is up on the wall why
not put up the David star on the world
would you agree this again what's wrong
with with the cross on the wall I don't
think it's wrong the David Cross the
star the David star yes or no what a
thing I wouldn't mind honestly and
what's about the symbol of Islam and for
us the this cross like the David star is
a symbol it's a simple for our culture
for our identity for our Christian
values and for that I would accept that
we discussed that the danger with Islam
is that it mixes politics with religion
this is what Marcus do
isn't it no I think he quite clearly he
quite clearly stressed and pointed out
why he put the cross on the walls in the
official state bill but honestly and it
was exactly the the potentially a very
important politician having his cross in
his hands again we are and I believe
that it is a point we are discussing the
danger that religion and states are
mixes what is this if not mixing
religious with politics
well I I answered with a question to you
what what's wrong you know
with making a reference visibility and a
visibility to the earliest which you
share because perhaps you know you don't
know know so everybody also hang signals
yeah but not but not in the state why
not you are the Christians are the owner
these are state Wars nobody owns them
there is not one religion who has to be
privileged it's not a privilege of a
religion because the cross is not used
by Marco Sudha is a religious symbol
it's used as you know showing what is
our identity what is our culture but
what are the well use which we share
here in Bavaria and for that as a symbol
you have the cross you know referring to
the human dignity referring to
solidarity and things like that and for
that I think for that it's I think it's
okay in times like this where people are
where so many things are going on you
know people have to be reassured you
know what about our our values and what
they stand for in Christianity but there
is one the measure may be aimed at the
various Catholic majority but even
Cardinal Ryan have marks with the
chairman of the German Bishops
Conference said it caused quote
divisions and this quite well you say
mr. marks there houston thority yes our
church I highly appreciate Cardinal
marks but he continued in in having a
debate you know with us also on what is
meant by that and I think and now he is
also stressing that no one is against
you know using the the cross as a symbol
and of course it's always important to
to underline that there is no
discrimination of other religions that's
important but again it's not wrong I do
not see that anything is wrong here if
you refer to your cultural identity also
in public building I get a kadhi blur
thank you for being on conflict zones
was a big pleasure
it was my realize it was my pleasure
merchants leave all the rest for you
thank you thanks hello
[Music]
[Music]